[Music]
Runk hey hey what's up I'll be an Oxnard
this weekend Friday and Saturday Oxnard
California get your tickets at chris.com
Sacramento is up uh Brea California is
up Phoenix Arizona El Paso Albuquerque
and I got some more dates on on sale
here Colona
BC Vancouver BC Rochester New York
uh I got it dude uh kitner
Ontario um shreport Louisiana Houston
Texas Corpus Christie March 16th never
been there uh Durham North Carolina and
norfol Virginia norfol can't I think it
sounds like f Youk but it's not um so
yeah there you have it that's where I'm
going to be coming up go to chris.com to
get tickets new dates and it is all new
stuff it is not from grower die my
special which you can get at chrs
lea.com so go watch that now and then
you can still come to the shows it's
that's two different hours um I work
hard because I want to make people happy
you know it's good and it's
also it it also you know what I mean
it's an insecurity but I want to make
people happy so um yeah I want I want
people to think I'm good enough is
basically what it is but anyway getting
too deep to to in this for my shows but
yeah go to chris.com and then also get
merch we got the grower die merch coming
in uh strong it's good people are
starting reposted stuff it looks great
on you so go to chia.com for all your
needs no matter what need you have
really uh and also this is the new
episode of
[Music]
congratulations you know we um I did the
uh well we got well no here update well
let me do an update look Christmas is
coming up you know my wife goes
absolutely nutty when it comes to
putting Garland and different lights and
places and you know candy canes candy
cane what's that from the that one that
one horror movie candy
cane
um and uh so we have I don't know how
many Christmas trees honestly I really
don't what's see one
two we have two up but there are more in
the garage gez anyway she was like let's
get let's go get one and I because we
have fake ones cuz have fake Christmas
trees because real one it's weird to
bring a real Christmas tree inside now
it's also weird to bring a fake one
inside right trees should only be
outside Jim gavan has that funny bit
about Christmas where it's like why do
you bring the outside inside I don't
know what it is it's I you know and um
but it's true like
why that's so weird to put all the oh
yeah yeah he says you put all the stuff
inside outside on the front lawn and all
the trees inside yeah but it's like
weird and then and then people will put
a fake tree I don't know if you this is
part of his bit or not but you put a
fake
tree which is even weirder but it's
better because at least it won't catch
on fire you know what I'm saying like
trees are so flammable because that's
literally what you put in the fire to
create a
fire oh the fire's going out well put
more trees in it so putting a tree in
the living room it's a bad idea
especially cuz you usually put it next
to the fireplace I feel like I'm doing
Jim Gavin's bit I don't know if this is
close to it or not I saw it years and
years ago but it's very odd and uh I was
hip with the fake trees and now of
course my wife is like how do you want
them decorated and I say well I like
them when they're green and when they
have all the the ornaments that are all
different from the families you know we
put them together and they look it looks
mismatch and everything so she got a
white tree and decorated like a Macy's
like Macy's tree with with just like all
gold balls and red balls and and so and
what do we do with the with the with the
ornaments and I had to open My Big Mouth
where I'm like well you know we didn't
use ornaments and she was like but don't
you like it I'm like I do like
it my favorite kind of Christmas tree is
the green one where we can you know and
she was like you don't like it I'm like
I love it it looks great it just looks
like you know it would be in Macy's
which is beautiful wants it to look good
that's the whole reason why it's in
Macy's and then she's like well uh her
answer I open my big mouth well you know
what do we do with the other ornaments
she's like well let's go get a real tree
so now we got another
tree that's a real tree that just got
delivered and let me tell you this
man by the way trees are just like it
it's like it's crazy that you spend
hundreds of dollars on the tree and them
delivering it and everything like that
and they just come and and it's just
just like you could go get one for free
you know um but anyway it was actually
such a magical moment bringing Calvin
and Billy to the um I mean Billy didn't
really know what was going on he's eight
months old but Calvin was just like
loving running around into the tree
which one which one you want to pick he
was like he was like oh I don't know and
we were we'll pick one he finally picked
one
and my heart was swelling but we went to
uh we went there and then we came back
and then they couldn't deliver it that
night so they delivered to delivered it
today anyway so we have another
Christmas tree which is great and we've
got it decorated so that's great and so
that only means that the ornaments that
we put we brought back downstairs to not
use we got to bring back upstairs again
so and yes dude and I got here's the
thing I open up my big mouth saying what
are you doing to my wife when she was
bringing the ornaments back downstairs
she say I'm bringing the ornaments
downstairs and you're not helping why
don't you help it I was like oh fck I
open my big dude I have to you know what
I got to stop doing is opening my big
mouth that's what I have to stop doing
is opening my big mouth but I open my
big mouth dude because I'm a comedian
and it's my job and now I have 350
episodes of this congratulations podcast
and other podcast I talk so much it's
all documented and it's all bad I don't
need to be talking so
much and I do hours of standup and it's
like dude my whole job is talking and
it's like every now every day I just
becoming a monk and just being taking
that vow of silence seems better and
better and I would like to do that
except for there's no way I could do
that you know why because I get pissed
off and why because I have to explain
myself and why do you have to explain
yourself because I want people to
understand me and why do people have to
understand
me you know why we just get to the point
where I go
because you know I was talking to my
therapist and she's like well you have
you don't like to be misunderstood and I
go and I'm like yeah I know I don't like
to be misunderstood I hate to be
misunderstood you know and you got to
let that go you got to let that go dude
I don't mean to be like a Steve Harvey
Show right now but you know you got to
let that go because people are going to
understand you no matter
what uh uh but it's you know what I mean
it's
like I don't
know I
just I want
to like the other day I've been talking
about junk food with with you know it's
so dude you know how easy it is to give
your
child [__]
food you know why because it's
around and you know what's not
around stuff that's good for
you it's just not even if you go and you
go to like a nice Market where you're
like oh let's get the nice snacks any
snack is like bad for you in a package
you know unless you're just going to get
like y okay you want [__] uh cucumbers
right but my son's not going to eat that
[__] like what is he a a jungle boy you
know like what
no so he's like I want a cliff bar so
I you
know I so Kristen's like what do you
think you want to give him a cliff bar
and I'm like nah I don't think so maybe
you got to eat something healthy you
know because you atat the ice cream cake
because it was somebody's birthday
earlier so don't eat that you know
remember I said you can't have a cliff
bar so he's like all right so she said
well what about
uh apples and uh peanut butter and I go
like this well peanut butter is junk
food you know and he says no I just want
peanut butter and she says okay and I
was like
well but before that she was like want
pasta and he was like yes she's like we
have it with pink sauce do you want it
with pink sauce and he says no I want
red sauce and I was like well you shut
yourself in the foot you should have
just went to go ahead and make it you
should have just made it you had to get
specific with the pasta
right and she was like and she was like
well she didn't want want anything I had
to give him peanut butter and I was like
I know but we got to start giving him
something better and I was talking about
this in front of the kid and I don't
want to like I you know the last thing
you want to do is undermine a parent
when you're a parent you don't want to
undermine the other parent you got to be
a united front right so she was already
like let how about peanut butter so I
was like yeah give him peanut butter you
know and it was all a whole mess you
know and I dealt with it not so great
but it's like I you know I just want the
kid to not be a fat [__] you know and
it's not even fat fat on the inside you
know like fat in your heart like that's
what I mean like it's okay to be fat a
little bit it really is okay to be chub
chubby not fat but like a chubby like a
like a not a good it's okay to not have
a good body right if it's you know what
it's okay it's okay to just be a guy or
a be a man or a woman and just like
that's you know you're just someone
right like not everybody has to be
ripped I get it you don't all have to
look like Thor you don't all have to
look like Wonder Woman you could just be
someone out there with like a pear shape
a little bit but you still don't want to
be eating this [__] the the the like
Skittles and like my son loves Skittles
the good thing is he's he's you know
he'll be like oh here's four Skittles
and he's like oh I get four and it's
like yeah and it's like okay that's good
but like that that's like what for me
that's like maybe 20 for me so it's like
if iight 20 Skittles and then my son be
like I have a tummy a and I'm like well
you know I want to be like did it to
yourself but I did it to him and I can't
say you did it to yourself to
four-year-old cuz then he's going to be
like I'm
bad so you got to be like well you know
it's okay it's probably because of
Skittles and I'm seething inside because
I'm like well you shouldn't be eating
[__] Skittles
but mom tossed them over to you I don't
know it's just it's all it's just
parenting is is and we and it's easy for
us you know because we have you know we
we're together we have money and all
this [__] but it's still the little it's
the subtle things that'll [__] you up
dude it's the subtle things that'll [__]
you up God it is
wow subtlety huh oh subtlety
man I don't know I was watching uh TV
last night I was over I was with David
Sullivan uh who you might know for my
tour reports and
uh and
whatnot I was with uh him and uh he was
like man can we watch a good thing and I
was like nah man we got to watch stuff
that's like not that good dude and we
could like be funny and laugh at it and
we passed by that movie sound of freedom
is that what it is yeah sound of Freedom
he was like this supposed to be good and
I was like it is supposed to be good
yeah all right okay we'll watch it I
turned it on dude let me just tell you
man the whole
movie I'm just like
this I mean it's really hard to watch
there's no like real violence or
anything you know the kidnapping and
it's just like I can't believe they made
that movie to be
honest like it's crazy I know it was an
independent movie but but I get like
Hollywood is just like we I don't what
what movie is that
we sound of
music I'm sorry
what with the lady with the the hills
are alive when she's with her skirt and
the apron I love that one anyway have
you seen you know have you seen Mickey
blue
eyes I mean dude sound of freedom is
harrowing it was really hard to watch I
wanted it was like one of those movies
where it's like they take all the kids
they kidnap the kids and then it's like
based on a real story and you don't know
how much of it is true but then you you
know it doesn't matter how much of it is
true cuz if any of this is true it's
terrible and
then and then you're like you watch some
of it and you're like I I said to David
I'm like I don't think I could watch
watch this and he's like yeah it's
really unsettling huh but then it's like
you want to watch it because you want to
get to the end to make sure that
everyone ends up okay you ever like
watch a movie and stop watching it like
this is how dumb I am I'll watch a movie
that has nothing to do with me with
madeup characters like that's a
fantastic movie about like dwarves and
elves or something and I'll start it and
I'll I'll I'll be like ah I don't want
to watch this I'm going to turn off go
to bed I go and I and in bed I'm I'm
like I hope everybody probably works out
for them I mean I didn't see the movie
but I I hope everybody's okay they don't
even exist and there's a real movie
that's based on a real story and you're
like okay I got to see this through
because I know that probably he saves
her at the end so I did I watched it and
I'm just like
dude and then you go on Google and you
like Google like these these rings of
these these pedophile rings that like
get broken up by by a like the the FBI
or whatever it is and it's like oh my
God bro bro this stuff really happens
and it's
like really really sad it's one of those
things where it's like you
know you know how like crazy [__]
happens in the world but it's so far
removed from you that you're just like
does that really happen like even like
outbursts in like a bagel
shop like I have a friend that always
has nuts
stories and he's just like oh you know
what happened I saw a homeless lady and
she lifted up her shirt and showed me
her titties and uh then she got hit by a
car and then rolled all over the hood
and then slid down and when she slid
down on this driver's side of the car
the shirt was still up and and their
titties slipped on the were just
like on the side of the driver's window
and the driver just started like being
like Oh God and like pulled over and
like are you okay and then they just
started dating and you're like that
didn't that H oh yeah you know oh you
don't believe it but you know you're
like I I guess he's not lying but you're
just like I'm so far remov of that that
I don't I don't believe it or not that's
just some something that somebody said
and uh the whole thing is too bad even
if it's doesn't exist it's too bad he
said it but like you know this [__]
happens and it's just
wild you know and you don't really think
about like I think the normal regular I
don't know what that even means nowadays
but the regular person who thinks like
we had Sam tripley over on uh uh golden
Hour podcast and he was talking about
all these conspiracy theories and like
how he thought that you know there was
an advanced civilization that was living
hundreds of years ago
and they we they got wiped out and how
you know whatever the there's a bunch of
different conspiracy theories and and
it's
like now that there's the internet it it
it's it's so weird when you start going
down that rabbit hole it activates your
brain because I'm like dude I don't
believe in I don't believe in a lot of
most of the conspiracy theories right
you know I'm using that term loosely
conspiracy theories has a negative
connotation connotation some of them are
true but like like the JFK one you know
it wasn't just the one dude in the
window 900 years away with a [__]
single shot
Pap um you know those kinds of
things and
uh Justin Trudeau is Fel Castro son but
it's like it's like uh the whole thing
with what was I trying to say like you
don't you
don't like you start looking in that's
what the thing they said look into it
you start looking into it you go oh all
right oh oh oh really well that's
interesting you start doing all that
[__] and it's like 2: a.m. and you're
just like what you start making that
noise you're like what you click
something and you huh and it's grainy
but you zoom in yourself like you're a
[__] like you're in a like your Tom
Cruz in a movie zoom in there you even
say it out loud and it's just you hold
on zoom in there and then you you go
like this to yourself I'm way ahead of
you
what oh my God is that
him and then it's like I go to bed and
then the next morning I wake up and I'm
still buzzing off this like well what
the [__] man how did they make the
pyramids how'd they do that though if
they how did they do it though if we
don't know how they did it and we're Way
Beyond them
TimeWise how's that
happened so we should be able to figure
it out we should at least be able to
figure out how they did it let alone do
it we can do it but they didn't have the
technology so it's like huh so then
you're sitting here you got that 2 A.M
brain and you're just like what the huh
what do hold on look that up I'm way
ahead of you
what
so then I'm I'm like walking around and
I'm like dude hold on a second
man hold on a second I go I I'm
like
TV I'm
like cell
phones I know I'm talking to someone on
the other line and I know who that
is but they're not near
me oh oh so it goes into the satellites
floating in space so that I'm like man
all this [__] like if you just put me
here and started telling me all this
stuff I go like this what so if all that
can be true then anything can be true
dude there's satellites that float
around in space and you can talk to your
friend that's
downtown and I'm just like wait a
minute zoom
in I go hey I want to talk to my friend
and then in my head I I'm way ahead of
you
hello and I'm just like what so dude
something's going on now I'm not saying
Joe Biden's a lizard and he goes into
the ocean and sheds himself cuz I don't
think that that's true but then I'm like
seeing a picture at Joe Biden at the
beach and I'm like wait on minute zoom
in he's shiny is that
him I'm way ahead of
you you could just make a show dude like
serious seriously you could just make a
show like that show 6 feet under that
was a show that they just acted in and
then just beamed it to us on a channel
on our box in our [__] living
room you ever think about this [__] like
let alone a
car imagine if you imagine if
you like if the world blew up and it was
the apocalypse and then you had had to
like start from scratch right there were
no dealerships anymore and you know GM
and they just they were like we don't we
can't do it anymore it's just too hard
and people are dying of
scurvy so let's focus on getting fruit
not Dodge Rams you'd have to like make a
vehicle right to get you know because
you know they could make them so you're
like I got to make it somehow it would
take you years to make a vehicle just
being someone that you are right now not
a vehicle maker like I'm a comedian if
you were like hey Chris no more cars if
you want to get down to the bottom of
[__] you know Coldwater Canyon then
what you got to do is make a vehicle and
I go I go oh [__] I don't think I can do
that but maybe I'd be able to figure it
out figure out okay now that's
cars talk and but then I'm like talking
to my friend downtown though with no
delay and using a
satellite to do so and I'm just like
okay well something else is going on
though
right you're GNA beam
news to my
eyeballs I don't know dude if you were
just plopped here you'd have so many
questions and we sit here and we don't
ask questions because we've been
here how nuts is that
dude
I don't know man something's up
something is up something's a foot right
something's a foot and it's not just my
feet man I was doing kid jokes to Calvin
the other day and they were so bad dude
and they were he's not at the age where
he can even really
like get it yet because he doesn't know
the you know it'll be like hey what did
zero say to 8 and they'll be like what
and I'll say nice belt and he's like
what and I'm like no because well
because zero uh if if you take a zero
and an eight if you take a zero then you
squeeze it then that's what it it looks
like an eight like that right and he
goes oh I'm just like all right it's not
working you know it's
like but then he was doing the thing
where he was
like I'll do a joke and I'm like okay go
ahead and he says what
is uh uh what is a
car and I'm like I don't know and then
he'll and then what he'll say is no I do
the joke and then you say what it is and
I'm like yo okay what is a car and I say
I don't know does it have four wheels
and it it drives and he says I think it
is I'm just like that's such a bad joke
you know but it's so funny that he's
doing it
so in a way it's a good joke right it's
not about what you say it's how you say
it and he killed it my son's a
comedian I love the stalinesque no no no
you answer
me we started the with the computer with
one uh perc and now we're at 24%
absolutely beautiful absolutely
beautiful now that's just gorgeous
that's gorgeous
thinking what the [__] liver King
dude why are we I know I've talked about
this before in the podcast but like dude
we just
pretend well not even with liver King
but like the
rock
like
hey ah you do
steroids you
know you do St hey dude liver King you
do steroids you know why you look like a
beetle I want the rock to admit that he
does steroids and I want him to just be
like that's the thing though he probably
wouldn't get any deals though after that
well not not not any deals he would
still be huge and stuff oh that's the
whole how could you live that
way no knock on it but like to be a
brand like that and to not live
authentically and I'm not you know I
don't know maybe the rock is being that
is authentic self but that's really
weird if it is it can't I mean but just
like I want the rock to just fire off
some mean tweet at some
point can't trust somebody that doesn't
have a knee-jerk reaction every now and
then you know God but that's what me
going back to my you know I need to be
more of a monk right what is liver King
doing this
look let's look at his last
video do I have to sign in wow I hate
Instagram like
that
we won't we won't look we will what's
his name liver King liver
King bro you can't tell remember the AI
thing here it looks like to be a
dominant man a dominant dad a dominant
husband and a dominant CEO to express my
highest and most dominant form in these
respective roles this is the way of the
Barbarian never out
[Music]
it's look somebody commented great
ideals to live by dominate everything
and the guy's
serious again but you see this people
you see how destroyed it is depth
perception killing from a distance a
whole new challenge but there's one way
to overcome it now get the [__] out of
my
way why why does he have the music
that's in like a lifetime movie when two
people are on a date in
it go dude I I hate that [__] like that
[__] with like you know what would have
that was Gray's Anatomy why do they do
that like oh hey I didn't see you
there oh sorry I was
just I was looking for a candy bar in
the thing but you know you go
first
anyway here you go you know I have a
question for you
Blom
yes never never
mind okay
by here at
AutoZone like why do they do you know
why because the show
sucks
that's why because the show [__]
sucks you know what I'm saying that's
why if the show didn't suck you wouldn't
have to
put in it
dude just have the scene where he can't
ask her
out the thing is I wanted
to it's a little high hat that that
really pisses me the [__] off
too uh uh I don't know man Grace's
Anatomy maybe it's good I have no idea I
have no [__] idea I never saw
it uh Co apparel.com quality merch
services at fall filment uh karl.com go
to my page if you want to purchase a 10w
ad or shout out holler.
christalia
[Music]
um oh God Kim Kardashian's minimalist
Christmas this is a thing on
BuzzFeed you know I make fun of my my my
wife because she does so I I can't
imagine I was watching some of those
decorating shows because I like to do it
because like sometimes I put on my wife
is there I'm like I watch this [__]
maybe she'll like it and it's like there
what was it celebrity Decor I don't know
what it was called but this one guy was
just like I love decorating and he talks
like this and he's just like I love
decorating so much uh and I can easily
spend millions of dollars on decorating
a home my personal friends uh Sharon
Osborne we working for her and I
normally wouldn't get out of bed for
more than1 million but I do it because
she's a person a friend and it's just
like holy [__] [__] [__] would
you could you imagine having a deal with
a person like that imagine imagine that
oh these chair aren't they delicious
look at this just look at the way they
turn and the good thing is you could put
them inside and face them on the inside
or you could twist them and spin them
and look out on the Miranda isn't that
delicious
dude these are real people that talk
like this anyway these CH are 40 Grand
each and you're like oh
[__] it's just so ridiculous I don't
know what the show was called I forget
what it's called I watch a little bit of
it on Netflix and I can't
like I get it
look having a decorator is good you
don't have to do all this [__] but let's
see what she has uh Kim kardashia has on
her thing
um Grace say with a okay uh oh my
God Kim already has she has features a
ton of lit up trees waiting outside okay
Kim posted a v a video footage of her
sitting room and hallway it's worth
noticing that piano music was playing in
the
background he she hires him to play
festive
music Philip
Cornish uh she hires him to play festive
music in December yo that's
crazy put on a [__]
CD and get a
playlist I mean who's who's who's not
okay with just Frank Sinatra just being
like oh the weather outside is
frightful oh my god dude there's all
these trees in her hallway
that's cool the way it's lit up the tree
um beige everything's beige beige
stopping s on
christmy
um damn one less stocking cuz not Kanye
is there
huh uh there's a pink oh they got so
many Tre I can't show my wife this Jesus
Christ
this is the stupidest [__] article
I've ever seen in my life hey BuzzFeed
get it together I can't believe I I
clicked on that but good good props to
Kim
Kardashian
um
what appala what he say what she come on
Jay let Tupac recipes let them come on
appala what said what she said he got
alala Alaia but he did but tell me what
that is so Alia I mean you know but tell
me what that is alopecia dude how come
you can't say that appala also he's bald
you know actually no he isn't he is here
um we ain't need to know that but dog
Alle Legend he been dead 30 years appala
y alipa but um I know Albert Hughes he
recently talked about it like how they
were jeice and he has stress patches
which is like a former alipa and like
Shar the story of like why he cut his
hair off she should have told us a whe
story you're right talk about your
husband baby you married him tell us how
you fell walking down the carpet one
time and we ain't know you ain't have on
no panties or
something you know per got took a turn
for the pervy right
immediately I'm just tell us will po
gone he got appala alipa alipa alipa one
time for everybody with appala man you
know was way more than one time one time
for everybody with appala like that's
like somebody he went to school with
when he was in high
school that pelicia broke his
heart
um racist uh no but that's this guy I
don't know hey Rick Ross is [__]
failing upwards right I mean like we we
watch him as a train wreck him and DJ
khard we just there a train wreck and we
just keep funding it
right I you know I don't know it's like
you can do that in Hollywood you can you
can be a director even and like make
[__] nine bad movies and then just
get a 10th one it's
crazy these AI supermodels are getting
out of control I actually thought
it was
um I I saw one the other day that was I
thought it was uh real and my and I was
shown it and I and it was a video of
someone and they were just like on the
bed chilling like a hot chick just and
it was and it was real and I still think
it's real that's how good they're
getting like I get the pictures look
kind of fake CU and I don't mean like
cuz obviously you can't like catfishing
is just you can't there don't ever trust
anything anymore online period I think
we're at that point right like if you
meet somebody if you're on hinge or
whatever the [__] bum Bumble if that's
still a thing Tinder if that's still a
thing you go on there and you and you
meet and you see people and you just you
you kind of have to go off of their bio
because you know they're not going to
look the way they are unless they're
like super yeah I don't know man no not
even unless anything unless they don't
look good cuz then they're like oh well
they didn't even try to do a filter on
it but like dude they could straight up
make videos of people now that are fake
like dude there was a thing that they
there was a clip on Supernatural that
somebody sent me cuz I was talking about
supernatural and like you got to wait
till you get to this moment and it
showed a moment on Supernatural and it
was actually so ridiculous that I was
like dude I think that might be fake
that might be a fake thing that somebody
sent me on Supernatural like this is the
world we live in now so you could just
be basically chatting
nobody I can't believe how like
real it looked and they were telling me
dude this is fake and in the bio it said
AI not real and I and I'm like dude
they're [__] with us they're real cuz
I would maybe do that like pretend I'm
not real but then you are real and then
you show up and just blow people's minds
it's too bad I'm already famous because
if I wasn't
dude I'd have to get super fit
though i' have to get more fit right
yeah but whatever dude who
cares I want to
uh I want to get super fit but I I it's
just too much to takes too much time
sandre congratulations on graduating
keep up the good work Mama go to my page
if you want to purchase a 10 word add or
shout out holler.
christalia uh yeah dude
this is crazy this contract the sh Otani
sh Otani joining the Dodgers on a
10-year $700 million contract which is
like actually crazy that
any anything to do with baseball has
$700 million and I guess it's it's the
Dodgers so that's a pretty legit
organization this is the biggest
contract in the world uh and he is bro
bro H what was the last one was like
300,000 300 million million 400 million
maybe whatever yeah here I actually look
by more than 250 million topping the
12-year 426 mil ah Mike Trout I remember
that
[Music]
um wow this is crazy dude is baseball
has [__] money huh how about this man
H Asians figured it out in the in
baseball remember in 90s zero Asians all
of a sudden they had one Asian guy and
then all of a sudden some more Asian
guys and now this Japanese dude is just
like Shani goes like this he's just like
oh yeah we will see you and $700 million
for 10 years
dude what is that number in Japanese
each not each
a [__] I can't
remember what's
yeah je for [__] Jew years
dude dude $700 million for JE years
that's crazy
dude
wow
um anyway
he's like dude he's a pitcher and a the
best batter in the yo dude you know what
this guy's my hero and I've always loved
Asians and now he's my favorite one so
God imagine just [__] I would dude if
you had $700 million what would you
buy what would you [__] buy I'd buy
[__] straight up
like you know what would do is just get
like
H I would build a community of houses
and I would live in one and I would have
all my friends live in the other ones
and we would just [__] have a good
time dude we' have barbecues and then
I'd have a stage for standup and
uh you know just kind of ball out right
oh you know what I would do for real
open a cool coffee shop in in my house
with employees I know there's that joke
thing that I did with like on um was it
fighter and the kid where I said I got a
Starbucks in my house that went pretty
viral but like dude if if I had a coffee
shop in my house yo you know how much I
would love that for real waking up
downstairs you go into the kitchen you
go through the kitchen and there's like
a lit like a [__] Coffee Bean or like
a pach coffee with and you hear like
like grind and also people can go there
like it's not just me and I'm alone
there it's like people that are there
that like and I get annoyed with them
too sometimes where I'm like I gota wait
in this [__] line is my house like I
want to be able to get like why can't I
have a [__] priority [__] and then I
try to get priority but they're like we
actually don't do that here and I'm like
this is my house but like you get a
manager there and like a a barista and
like a few other employees and I pay for
it all I pay for the employees and I pay
for the and then you know shipments I
pay for the shipments to the coffee and
then we do things where like they come
in and they're like oh we we want to we
want to test some pastries out this the
you know and I I have to try them and
I'm like this one but not these you know
and then the next day some of the ones
that I said I don't want are there and
I'm like you guys [__] it up and like
just I need stuff to deal with basically
if I have $700 million I want stuff to
deal with in my house that would annoy
me and then
like but like it's not part of my house
but it is part of my house that would be
dope dude just a c
you
know my my wife would be like you didn't
do the thing and I'm like sorry I was
out
coffee I didn't get your
text that would be pretty dope I'd
probably still go get coffee though I'd
probably still drive down the hill and
do it because I want to be out you know
I like driving a little bit I would get
a driver for sure no doubt I mean I
could probably afford a driver but I
don't want that's the thing you need to
start making well Uber right but I don't
use Uber but I'd want a guy that I know
to do it I don't want [__] U I don't
ever want I don't even think I have Uber
on my phone but like I don't ever want
somebody I don't know that doesn't work
for a company not Uber Uber is like
freelance [__] basically I don't I need
somebody that works for a car company to
pick me up I don't want Uber just some
guy in a Hyundai with with like a hoodie
on listening to like Buster
Rhymes to drive me to the
airport that's so
weird um I want a guy in a suit right I
guess God I [__] came home I had a I
had a driver I came home from the
airport and I got the the the uh the
bags
out and the gate was opening and it
crunched his door and it [__] flipped
it backwards and so the door was open
the backwards way like it it like the
door opens and the the the gate was
going and it picked the door up and
opened it
[__] and he had to drive home with
the [__] door open the driver and I
was like oh my god dude I'm so sorry I
didn't know I had no idea the gate was
opening and I didn't know the car was
there and he was like it's okay they'll
deal with it bro they the guy just
showed up he had to drive home like this
he had to drive home holding the door
cuz it wouldn't
shut and I was like dude just let me
know if there's anything I need to do
like for the claim or the insurance he's
like it's all covered and then I was
like that's kind of cool you could just
[__] up the cars and like not have any
repercussions you
know you could just basically get a
hammer and be like yo thanks for the
lift [__] po
pop ah [__] dude hey let me know if they
need me he like oh well it's covered ah
[__] man
sorry just along the door dude I'll see
you next time have that all
fixed I didn't know it worked like that
oh I felt bad dude I felt
bad and then I came home and I was like
oh I feel so bad and I was like I feel
like it's my fault and my wife was like
it kind of was and I was like what dude
don't say that I need you to be
supportive and she was like yeah but
well I got to tell you how it is but
it's like but I was like it isn't really
my fault I was just saying that you said
it
wouldn't the guy parked too close to the
[__] thing I always want somebody's
fault I always want it to be somebody's
fault
dude God I always want it to be
somebody's fault my wife sometimes is
like you know it's not it's not
somebody's fault sometimes and I'm just
like I'll find out whose it
is I'll find out whose [__] fault
that is dude trust me I'll get to the
bottom of it I'm like Petty
Columbo
um anyway
dude I'm so [__] hungry I I can't see
straight dude and when I'm not when I'm
hungry I get
mad and I don't like hangry too when
that'll just make me more mad are you
angry n I'm hungry and mad I'm hungry
and angry hry nah I that's I don't want
to mix words together like
that
fantabulous you know when people say
stuff like
that um what else is another one uh it's
always
like
exclamations um fantabulous
uh uh ginormous dude my my my
videographer says ginormous I I I had to
pull him aside I'd be like y bro you
can't be saying that dude what are you
Mormon like that's some [__] that
[__] Mormons think is
funny Mormons don't have the greatest
sense of humor right let's just call it
spade a spade I mean there are great
Mormons out there but like how many
Mormon standup comedians are there you
know how many Mormon funny actors are
there you know they mostly are just
like okay you
know it's not like they're exactly
pushing the envelope in any way well I
mean with polygamy but they don't do
that but like certain sects
do God po you used to be able to have
like four wives like if you were a king
and
[__] where in the world can you do that
now I don't know but you can't do it in
America you know you just can't have
four wives right like isn't it like
against the law or something but like
kings used to just be like yo guess what
I love this one now so [__] it you know
and the other wife would be like okay
you know as long as she you
know my good sir and
then my question is I I wonder how
[__] more annoying it
is
right cuz like my wife is like hey after
Christmas let's go to the Bowl game in
Dallas mou's playing and I'm like why
the [__] do I get out of this right that
immediately so imagine saying that to
like four different
women oh [__] there would be
overlapping [__] you know there's like
there's that antique con convention and
You' be like oh [__] how do I get out of
this well I could say I got to go to the
bow game but I don't even want to do
that how do I get out of that and you
know what I just I hope I get
cancer you know what happened sweetie I
got hit by a truck you did yeah and then
just run into oncoming traffic so you
don't have to do anything I don't know
how well when you're the king though
what you say goes
right we it would be great to get to the
point to where if you were just like
some guy who like was a branch manager
at Wells Fargo could have like two wives
and honestly I don't think I think women
could have multiple husbands too like
I'm I'm not this isn't a sexist thing I
in a way I'm like dude maybe it might be
the [__] if I if I had another husb if
we and I'll marry him too dude I just as
long as I don't have to like jerk him or
anything just have him around have him
bring the ornaments downstairs and then
back up again when we decided to get
another tree that you went to get the
with the other husband and I'm just the
guy at home chilling in his [__]
coffee shop in his
house you know waiting in line with the
other husbands oh God damn it bro come
on man you got to [__] her last night
can I just jump please can I get the I
want to get four shots over espresso and
you get that stupid peppermint drink
anyway bro you're a cuck well I guess we
kind of all are in a way aren't
we that's
that's my wife would if she wanted to
see that's the thing though you think
like oh oh you want your wife to have
another husband too to help cuz here's
what would happen she'd get the guy
she'd get the guy who was like a little
Pudgy that would help that would be like
the cuddle guy and like the oh tell me
about your feelings guy but then she
would also get a ball player to marry
her too and you'd have to like come home
to like some [__] lineman and you're
like God this guy's [__] RI well
linemen are fat as [__] but like you
know a hockey player and you're like oh
he can fight he's ripped he's got such
good
balance and he's just like dude I'm
actually going to sleep in the bed
tonight you're like
G all right I'll take the
floor wide awake because you drank too
much coffee and
[__] you hear some long-haired [__]
Adonis freak just nailing her ah
whatever you know what sometimes you
choose to be mad cuz like my instinct is
to be like ah if somebody did that if
somebody like had sex with my wife I'd
be like well [__] that but then I'm like
ah [__] [__] man you could choose to not
be angry you know you really could is't
that crazy about
anger if you just sometimes stop like
the [__] you get mad at the petty [__]
if you just stop you're like hold up
hold up that doesn't really piss me off
if I just kind of control myself yo
that's
Bonkers like I'm so hung well no that
one doesn't work huh I'm so hungry that
I'm so and I'm so angry about
it cuz food is a necessity of life but
you know it's not when you're just like
cut off in traffic you could just and
now I'm getting mad thinking about it
getting mad thinking about
it I did my shoulders today at the the
gym too and that was the thing too
because it's like that's why I'm so
hungry cuz I [__] pushed it to the
Limit I did that [__] landmines dude
I went crazy with more and more
landmines I did more and more landmines
I did so many
landmines and
uh then I did the B the battle R I don't
know man I'm so [__] [__] tired and
hungry I appreciate you guys listening
though honestly I
do dude I think it that that this is the
thing I'm in my 40s this is what I
really honestly think I'm in my
40s and I think I got to the part in
life where I'm just like [__] now
what dude 40 more
years the kid part was dope you know but
also it was not dope too you had to deal
with like people wanting to fight you
and [__] like one time Milton my
neighbor was like oh I forgot to kick
your ass the other day and then beat me
up like that's something you don't have
to deal with as a 20 30 40 year old but
like life's been I got success I did my
thing as they would say
right um I sewed my oats and done a few
and it's just
like married kids and like I love being
with my kids and that's the thing I
really focus on is like my family but
then it's like and then the what
else cuz here's the thing I still love
doing standup but it's like so 40 more
years of it though I used to think I'd
never retire and now dude I'm like oh yo
bro you put 50 Millie in the
bank chill so chill dude
I'm just [__] hanging out watching
movies all day and I'm talking about
like Batman
Forever like just watching the shittiest
of the shitty eating only carbs I don't
give a [__]
bro get a
moat you know a mod around my
house
like what is life in your
40s cuz that's when you're supposed to
be the [__] as a
man you've got enough experience but
also you're still kind of like
youngish oh my
God because if I think about me in my
30s I was a [__] dum dum you
know I was funny and being silly and
[__] but I was living like a dumb dum
and now I'm living right but then it's
also
like do I have to just keep living right
for 40 more
years oh my god dude you ever get one of
those moments where you just got like
you're like oh my God I got to step back
and I just got to
chill
because you'll start to spin out and
have an anxiety attack I'm just having
one straight up during the podcast it's
not an anxi this is not an actual
anxiety attack but like you ever go to
bed and you're just like oh man what
happens when I die like bro when I was a
kid I would go to bed and I would think
what happens when I die and I would
start getting so nuts cuz I'm like well
either there's Heaven Or there's not and
if there is then fine but if there's not
then what happens it just stops and
there's nothing so what's not living
it's the absence of living but what is
that but it's not even not living it's
just nothing it's not even it's you know
it's just this but like what the [__] is
that and then I would start to my heart
would start to beat and then like I
stopped doing that because now I know
better when I start thinking about that
I just stop myself from thinking about
it and I just start thinking of
something else anything Tetris whatever
pops into mind but then it's like oh
[__] I still let myself go down that
rabbit hole sometimes and I'm in my
40s oh I guess I'm worried about
death I guess I am you know your parents
get older and you see it happen and like
then people start dying around you and
then like you're in your 30s and like or
20s and you know the first kid from your
high school you hear he died in like a
car wreck and you're like holy [__]
[__] you know that happened a while ago
somebody I died at when somebody in
college died and then it's like oh
[__] I'm really rambling and I'm sorry
and I'm just too hungry man whatever I
love you guys
um and it is what it is but uh yeah have
uh have fun in your life and have fun
and live each moment to the fullest you
know whatever the [__] to say I post I
appreciate you that's it for the YouTube
episode if you want the uh rest the
uncut episode uh go to patreon.com
christalia uh and you'll do that and uh
it's great and you can also catch all
the other episodes that uh that we shot
already uh the extra episodes for the
month uh for each month there's like 30
something of them maybe 40 even but
appreciate you guys
[Music]
thanks [__]
[__]